All right, so who do I think I am to be
teaching a graph ml class?
A personal history in graphs.
Uh so I majored in biology and then got
into QA automation. It was my first
software job and then did web
development. Uh got into network
visualization doing a startup in the
casino gaming industry.
Saw uh Cloudera series A in the New York
Times and got into big data. Uh then I
started doing machine learning at
LinkedIn in 2010.
Uh
I got into graphs
as I'll show you. Uh then I got into uh
crime fighting and most recently I work
at Walmart
on the people AI team.
Um so I'm here representing myself and
not them.
Um
so uh
I'm a startup CTO by career. Uh we did
some stuff at this company called Deep
Discovery, built a large knowledge
graph.
So in the beginning I I wanted to be a
better entrepreneur, so I got into this
concept networks of success.
There was this poster Silicon Valley
genealogy of uh the history of
companies. They all go back to the
Fairchild Semiconductor
and it was kind of the root of all of
the modern companies.
So I did one for the Atlanta security
cluster. Uh I met some founders and this
is a graph where the company is a node
and the edge is someone that worked at
that company and went on to found
a startup. That's another node.
This was in uh
Atlanta Business Chronicle.
Uh at Ning uh there was this problem
where the website wasn't growing and um
I did a graph analysis. This was like
manually laid out so I could get the
layout the same every day. But um
it's like a processing uh
app that visualize and what we found was
that the um
edge between the email sign up and the
actually res- responding to the emails
would got very thin after a certain
release. So it was helpful in debugging
that.
Uh then I worked on LinkedIn in maps. Um
this one had a timeline. It was like the
prototype of my brother's network. But
we found that when he labeled his
network everybody kind of wanted to own
one because it was their personal story.
So that's how the app works. Uh
I got into inbox collaboration networks
after that.
Uh
business graphs for sales and marketing
did a lead generation system and a
market intelligence system.
Uh it had a web app.
Then uh we built a 3 billion entity um
2.2 billion edge knowledge graph by
combining Cy Cyveillance and um
OpenCorporates to do uh know your
customer checks. Here the red nodes are
like known sanctioned individuals and um
the first and second degree connections.
So it had a cool interface we're
building.
This is the source of risk of Ivars
Zudars. He was involved with uh Yevgeny
Prigozhin.
We extended an OCCRP article covering
it.
And then uh I played with uh security
stuff using Graphistry.
Uh
we're going to use Graphistry to do
visualization here today.
Okay, let me get to the code.
Yeah, so there are five notebooks in the
uh GitHub repo. Um
one is uh knowledge graph construction
where we um
create a knowledge graph of uh is a
citation graph.
And um if you can just like kernel
restart and run all cells on this one um
it will uh start building the knowledge
graph for the other notebooks.
So, it's uh fairly straightforward um
you know, it's a heterogeneous graph or
network. Uh so, technically a graph is a
mathematical structure, and a network is
a real-world instance of that, but in
practice they're just sort of synonyms.
And um
So, the reason graph machine learning is
so powerful is that there are natural
networks like all over the place, like
social networks, the brain,
uh communication networks, like uh and
then there are also uh structural
networks that um you have to kind of
ETL, like uh scene graphs from uh an
image or software source code or 3D
shapes in a mesh.
So, raw data are often not networks, but
um the concepts they represent
underneath are usually actually a graph,
and that's sort of the source of the
power of of graph machine learning.
So, we have a custom uh instance as I
mentioned, but um
you can also set up Graphistry by
signing up for Graphistry Hub. And then
the um if you edit uh graphistry.env
uh
Um it's got this uh lot you can put this
in, but I think originally it had uh
hub.graphistry.com
with my login there.
So, um after class you'll be able to use
that.
It's cool. It lets you use their GPUs uh
to visualize your networks and
um they have a bunch of Streamlit
examples.
So, here we're building a um
I set up the parameters for Graphistry.
We're building out We're using NetworkX
here to build a a digraph, like a
directional graph,
uh based on the high energy physics uh
data set from uh
Stanford SNAP, Jure Leskovec's group.
So, we actually uh encode the um
the abstracts uh using sentence encoding
and a sentence transformer, so that we
can get at the that as a feature for
graph machine learning.
We set the node properties from the um
metadata associated with the paper. It's
various properties, like author,
uh some of this stuff I had to actually
manually parse and extract. This is not
uncommon when you're building a network
from real-world data. Uh you can see
here um who wrote it, what the paper
title is. So, um
I use this tool Pythex to build the It's
like a regex helper.
Um very helpful. I think it's
pythex.org.
Uh I'm not great at regexes, uh regular
expressions, and um
this sort of helped me build these. Uh
so, the date, all of these values, uh
who the paper was from, uh authors,
comments, uh the report number, uh I
forget what that corresponds to, but
then the journal reference is the
journal that it was in. You can see how
complicated that regular expression is,
but the um the regex helper really does
assist you in creating that.
So then here I retest the information
extraction. You can see it's a
well-structured document.
So here I'm looping through the tarball
to extract the data and uh build the
network. This is a temporal network in
that um there are timestamps on the
papers and there are on timestamp on the
edges, which are citations. So um quite
often in network analysis, it was
popular to ignore time for uh a long
time. Uh but of course, like for
example, when we were building uh
like a business graph to do um
know your customer checks and anti-money
laundering work, um it was the case that
we could associate people uh with risk
through their business connections. Like
if you were on the board of directors of
a company with someone else that and
they had a risky company, uh you would
inherit some of that risk, but uh it was
a temporal graph and so if you didn't
account for that, if it was more than
like 7 years ago, the banks probably
didn't care. And so uh
it's often the case that um stale
relationships don't matter.
So we add a timestamp.
Yeah sorry.
Is that being annoying?
Okay.
So here um I'm using a uh
this all-MiniLM-L6, a common sentence
transformer. Sentence transformers are
uh a way of doing sentence encoding.
They're uh they embed uh paragraphs or
short documents. Uh there are some that
will embed longer documents now, but
they essentially encode the meaning of
the entire document. Uh early on, you
might do something with like word to
vec, the first uh text embedding, where
you would um simply average, you know,
all of the the tokens, the words.
Nowadays, you uh
tend to use something more
sophisticated, but the sentence
transformers library makes it very easy
to uh
to embed text, and then that can become
the property of a node for graph machine
learning.
So, here we're embedding the abstracts.
Uh here's an example. So, this K nearest
neighbor network wasn't that
interesting, actually, but it
demonstrates the principle. So, you can
a common method of knowledge graph
construction is
uh you can embed the nodes, and then uh
associate nodes that are nearby in the
embeddings latent space. So, if they're
similar, in other words, it will link
them.
And so, that's interesting for exploring
related papers and things like that.
This is the least interesting notebook,
I promise.
Um you can see we're working with
embeddings.
You can see here um
there's journal reference, journal ref
letters. So, what I'm doing here um
there was a problem where uh journals
need to be disambiguated. Their forms
varied.
Uh and so, this it's often the case with
knowledge graph construction. When
you're doing ETL, you have to use
machine learning, or uh you can't really
clean up the data enough to get it in a
structured form where your knowledge
graph has a lot of value. So, um
here uh you can see maybe
uh
some dupes. Um I guess I don't see
modern physical letters and physical
letters. I think these are the same
uh
journal. So, we embed them into uh
the reference, and there is a paraphrase
embedding as well. I compared two
embeddings.
And uh we cluster them. So, I just used
K-means actually. Um
it's uh
like a very simple clustering algorithm
uh that scales reasonably well. Uh
it's probably the most commonly used
algorithm.
So, I um
get the classes by taking the one uh the
K-mean centroid that it's closest to and
then assign the um class back to all of
the nodes
uh to get their um
journal reference to disambiguate
journals. The reason we're doing this is
that the um one of the problems we'll
use in a later notebook is to uh
classify
journal papers into their uh journals.
So, like some of them are not actually
marked where where they appeared. So, if
it's just like the Journal of Nuclear
Physics, we would assign a paper to uh
to that journal.
Um here we're using UMAP to do uh
dimension reduction to get a 2D
um representation and then DB scan is a
it essentially clusters the way you
would if you were drawing with a marker.
That's how I think about DB scan. If
they look kind of separate, it will
separate them in clusters. It works on
two-dimensional data. And so, you get
very easy to interpret uh clusters.
So, you can see here there's all of
these really long string formats. I
actually chopped some of these
uh and then they're extracted into the
the physics letters.
Uh so, this was actually the issue that
there were dates encoded with the
journal uh name.
So, then you have to nominate a label
for these clusters like um
you know, if if
you have a cluster, you can do it
manually at times. Otherwise, you need
to come up with an automated method. And
so, the simplest way is to um
group by the um literal value.
And then um
you know, look at the value counts. So,
I'm actually grouping by the cluster ID
and then look at the value counts. So, I
group by count and then use the most
common one.
So, um that works out to be a pretty
reasonable
um
number. Throughout these notebooks, I
talk about Chat GPT. This was created
like a year ago
uh for Italian students. And the use of
Chat GPT was not as ubiquitous to um
code. And so, I would use it to generate
text. And I was like, well, this isn't
really me. This is Chat GPT and me. It's
weird how it's gotten easier to accept
that Chat GPT's work is your own.
Um
Yeah, but uh it's really helpful to um
check definitions and things like that.
Where I think I know it, but uh when it
generates something that fits what I
know, it uh seems pretty good. So, here
we're actually
uh assigning the journal ID and then
assigning the most common um
the most common value as the the actual
name.
So, we plot our clusters. This is what I
mentioned. You can see they look roughly
like you would do. Um there are some
that simply don't fit in any cluster.
DBScan is kind of neat in that it won't
try to make bad data fit into a cluster.
It will just not assign it.
Um that may be an option or something,
but you can see the various journals
that this uh
paper archive covered.
Uh so, we assign the labels back to the
journals. I mean, back to the papers.
We assign it back to our network X
neighborhood.
Here we built a K nearest neighbor
network as I mentioned um
using uh
the uh abstract embedding.
So, if your data isn't explicitly
structured as a graph, you can uh
structure it based on the similarity of
your documents. If it's a text
distributed graph, um
you could also do this. You might embed
uh across multiple fields if it's more
like business data uh without long
string fields, you can do the the same
thing there.
So, you can see we're actually creating
the graph from the um neighbors index
that we just built.
Check one node's properties, looking
good.
It's uh 16,989
uh our KNN network uh no thousand nodes
with half a million edges. So, then uh
we visualize it in Graphistry. Um This
as I said, this isn't the greatest KNN
network uh but hopefully it demonstrates
the technique. This is uh Graphistry and
um if you're now wanting to interact and
stuff seeing how cool it is uh I'll just
flash these for a moment again. Um
These are the
um
credentials for uh Graphistry. If your
name starts between A and N, use
uh the top login. If your name starts
with N through Z, use the bottom one.
These are in the file
envs/graphistry.env.
You can also just edit the .env uh file.
They're both imported.
I'll wait like 60 seconds for people to
take this down.
With both of them or um
I think the rustle ones are working for
me. Um
Which one didn't work?
Uh yes, actually.
Yeah.
Okay, so that's a good tip. Once you
edit this file, you do need to docker
compose down and docker compose up. So
that will
reload the environment variables.
All right. Um
>> So, uh
I'll demonstrate more of its um
interactive capabilities in a minute,
but um
you can see this is a paper with a high
centrality. I think it's default degree
centrality that it uses, but um
you can navigate the properties
um
it's got degree and these things as a
property. We're going to compute a bunch
more properties, but um
you can actually uh get this in its own
window,
uh which is generally what you want to
do.
Then these are shareable uh
like if if you use the Graphistry hub,
they're shareable on the internet, uh
but the URLs aren't public until you
share them, so it's sort of private. Uh
that's not good enough for like a
enterprise context, so you can use their
cloud version or uh they have enterprise
offerings if you're like a big company,
but the SaaS offerings are really
reasonable, so that's why I use this
that it's actually usable uh
in a business context as well.
Uh so as a final exercise uh to use LSH
networks and face, but we don't have
time to uh really run through it. This
is uh the more interesting part of uh
class, I think, uh the network science
component. Um
There are millions of network science uh
papers, and uh they primarily seek to um
use the methods of network science to uh
prove hypotheses, and that's really the
strength of network science. Um it tends
to be a descriptive uh you know, field
um
um some people uh from the machine
learning world will critique network
science and say sort of like, "Well,
they don't actually do anything. They
don't build anything." Um
uh but um especially when you use this
stuff with machine learning, it's
really, really powerful.
So, I mean, if you want to learn network
science, this uh the section textbook is
um network science by Albert
Laszlo-Barabasi. He came up with um a a
theoretical network type, a random graph
that's uh
very important. I can't remember if it
was small worlds or um
something else. Um
So, there are the graph history setup
instructions again.
If you have something that uh network X
is a cool library, uh sometimes it
doesn't scale because it's uh sort of
single-threaded. Uh
you can use a network called networkx,
all one word. It is uh multi-processing,
so you can throw like 50 cores at a
problem or whatever. Often, things that
won't run in network X will run very
quickly. Uh the other angle is that uh
cuGraph uh is uh networkx style API.
It's very similar where you can use GPUs
to to
perform algorithms. And so, if you want
to do something like closeness or
betweenness centrality, very inefficient
centralities where you have to look at
every path in the network, uh you can
use a GPU and make those run, whereas
they would never finish uh on a
single-threaded uh
file. Um the s- thing I'm doing here is
um
the libraries I use to sample little
ball of fur and uh to embed the graph
embeddings, karate club, um they both
require uh integer
node IDs. Uh so, um I'm assigning I'm
building an index and assigning them to
uh
that
um
So, the the thing we're doing here that
I want to highlight um and I often do
this in PySpark and GraphFrames, which
I'll show uh later, but um
you could just load this data in a graph
database up front, right? Like just the
abstract and then extract the data from
there.
Uh there's a couple issues with that.
That tends to put you in JVM land.
Whereas when you're doing ETL, I
mentioned you use machine learning, you
probably want to be in Python land.
Um or R land or whatever your favorite
uh language for that is.
And so, um it's often helpful to build
data flows to construct a knowledge
graph using Pythonic tools and then
store it in a graph database when you
need to do point-wise queries. Graph
databases uh so, there's so many now
that this not entirely true, but
traditionally they've been better at
point-wise queries. Uh you know, using
indexes, but if you want to
uh perform an algorithm on all of the
graph, they tend to fall over. I think
Neo4j has a version in the cloud that
got like a 100 times speed-up on that
kind of algorithm, but it's not in the
enterprise product yet or the um
the uh open source one.
So, here's a utility we're going to use
to um describe a an entire graph, uh the
number of nodes and edges, uh the mean
average degree. Degree is just how many
connections a node has. Uh mean and
median will compute. Um
This is connected components. So, uh can
you get from node A to node Z? Uh if you
can't, those are in separate components.
So, it's uh usually the case in
real-world networks that you'll have
like a really big hairball component.
It's like 2/3 of the data and then uh
they'll get smaller and smaller in kind
of a long tail
distribution.
So, you can see it. This is applied to
the
citation network that we built
out of the high energy physics
network. Um,
one thing I found that's helpful if I
want to check kind of what I think or if
I'm not even sure like what what the
summary metrics mean is you can ask
Claude or ChatGPT to actually interpret
the metrics from network science and
they do actually a really good job. Um,
you know, you probably want to check
their results to ensure they're sane,
but um, that was really surprising
actually when I wrote this. So, here we
compute the connected components and um,
plot them so you can see the long tail
distribution I mentioned.
Um,
there are many that
have
a small number of nodes and then there
are a few that
all the way up 10 to the fourth, you can
see there's one large uh,
component.
You have to run on many algorithms in
network X undirected networks. This is a
digraph. So, use digraph.undirected
to um,
generate an undirected network.
So, here we also compute clustering
coefficient.
Clustering coefficient means um,
the uh, I believe the number of nodes
possible and the number of nodes
connections that it actually has.
Parker, I think I'm screwing that up.
Um,
but uh,
Oh, it's how connected the neighbors
are. Yeah, so I'm given the number of
neighbors, how connected are they?
Uh, so this is a really useful
uh, metric to understand how um,
embedded a node is in its context.
Um, it would be sort of like um, you You
five friends and if they know each
other, you're probably a tight-knit
group. If they don't know each other,
then um
you know, you probably got you're
hanging out with them independently
would be an interpretation.
Um
So, here we plot a histogram of the
clustering coefficients. Um
these are log uh
plotted um
You can see it varies quite a bit. Uh
you can use this to get kind of a
fingerprint on a network.
Sorry, quick thing. You just need to
amend the cell screen for students to um
leave the graph disk to serve from the
graph database or I just kind of go to
the um the
um
settings.
Oh, I didn't put a host name.
Oops. Yeah, one two three four one two
three for the server right here.
Uh
not sure what's up there. If the
credentials don't work, you can sign up
for Graphistry Hub, which I guess is
what I'm going to um
do.
Is this what you put? Yeah, no, I think
it it works fine. Yeah. Uh I think I
have to reboot the Docker container. I'm
not going to do that because it takes a
minute to load. Um
but
>> can do or you can just run CDL running
there or something.
That's a good point.
>> I don't think I have to actually.
Usually there's an hour at the beginning
of class where everyone gets everything
working. Um
Not sure. Is this what you had?
Okay. Um
Oh, it's protocol.
Um
let me go back to what I had in the
beginning.
Yeah, it is.
Wait, now it's not working what I had
originally.
That's weird.
Uh
This is dangerous.
I don't think so.
I think you have your last name in two
months.
No, that I don't have.
I don't know. What did I do? Uh
Aha. Okay. So,
I'm back on Graphistry Hub, which is
good. These are some uh parameters that
I like to start with. Um
the point opacity, if you turn it down
when it's densely connected, you can
start to see the edge opacity especially
needs to be turned down.
Um edge curvature, if things run slowly,
you can turn it off. It's really cool,
and people don't like networks that are
rendered with direct uh straight edges.
They like curve splines. Um we show
arrows. Uh the gravity controls how uh
small the network will render. Uh
there's a bunch of different layout
algorithms, actually, and then it
shortens labels.
You can have it show points of interest,
and it'll show like uh nodes that stand
out, which is kind of neat.
So, here we're loading the physics
network. Uh can doing the ID uh the
integer ID conversion that I mentioned.
Uh we have 27,000 nodes and 352,000
edges.
Um
Oh, I scrolled up. Okay.
Oh, uh yes, so node sampling. We're
going to cover this in more detail, but
um if you have to sample a network, just
uh doing a random sample is a good way
to uh screw up the properties of the
network and get like kind of bad data
and results. Um
the uh hack way to do it that was
recommended by uh
Faloutsos and uh Leskovec in this paper
sampling from large graphs is uh if you
sample at least 15% and you weight the
sample by the page rank of the nodes,
then uh you get something that still
preserves its uh structural properties.
They also came up with this uh fire
something or other uh algorithm that
that works well, but um this is a really
simple algorithm that uh little ball of
fur also implements.
So uh we remove all the degree zero
nodes from both subgraphs. Sometimes you
can do this, sometimes you can't. In uh
the KYC AML world, even if something's
uh not connected, you probably still
want to surface it
uh if it matches like a on the
properties, for example. Other times a
disconnected paper, if we're looking at
citations, is not really interesting, so
we can simply get rid of it.
Um
that trims the network down to uh
around 45 or 4,800 nodes with uh
depending on how we filter it uh
35,000 or 61,000 nodes.
Um here's a degree weighted sample that
works on the same principle. Um
uh what did I do? Uh
You can adjust the settings here uh for
the rendering.
Um
And then you can re-render, which is
pretty cool.
So
uh
that gets something a little easier to
work with. Um
So you can see kind of uh
what this looks like. Um
Then you can compute metrics. Uh let me
pop this up into a
new uh
workbook.
So um you can add histograms, which are
neat and we'll and we're going to
compare the different uh metrics we'll
compute. Kind of the methods of network
science using uh
both the size of the node and the um
colors of the nodes. So um
we could
uh
So at the moment we've just sort of got
like degree.
We could um
This shows you a histogram of degrees,
which is kind of cool on its own, and
then you can use it for point sizes. So
um sometimes this will change things, so
you need to improve like it'll they'll
all become big or uh So you can adjust
the point size this way.
Um
Can I increase the edge opacity a little
since it's a smaller sample?
Uh maybe not.
Uh but oh, that was point opacity. So
you can turn it down and you can tell as
you get it around the right area that
things become more navigable.
Um
Going back to the
scene, you There are think other layouts
you can use like you can um
dissuade hubs. Uh sometimes these things
So you can get a much more spread out
network that often forms a circle. Um So
this might be easier to work with uh
than the previous. So you can kind of do
different things. You can also
adjust label properties.
Um
This is kind of cool. You can
see if you want to hide So if you click
a node,
it highlights just its neighbors.
So you can adjust this actually to
highlight just the incoming or outgoing
edges
or not to highlight neighbors. You can
also do more than one hop.
So we'll start with uh
So that's a that's the set two hop
sample off of each of these nodes. So
that's kind of neat.
So then comparing that to a page rank
weighted sample,
and there's this handy
center button.
Uh it's not working at the moment. Um
cuz they're all spread out.
But um
you can see the structure is a bit
different. Um
So if you're having trouble running
this,
we make a copy of the original graph and
then you can substitute
for G the page rank sample,
the degree sample. If you're having
trouble with speed, I suggest you do
that. Then here you can go back to the
original if you want to play with that.
Um
I think I already ran it, so I'm going
to leave it how it is.
Um
Here we get the degrees and the in
degrees and out degrees and uh
we plot them. So use the degree
histogram,
the in degree histogram,
the out degree histogram. You can see
that Let see if these are
Oh, they're not aligned.
So, it's a little bit difficult to
interpret. We should have done that in
the, uh, chart, actually. It's a bad
visualization. Um,
So here uh
we're removing, uh, the unsighted
papers, as I mentioned, degree zero.
Here, we're going to add whether a, um,
node is a bridge,
which means, uh, if you cut that, uh,
if you remove that node, does it
separate components? So, would they
become two separate components? So, is
it a bridge between them?
Um,
assortativity, uh, defines, uh, it's a
metric that indicates whether connected
nodes have similar properties in terms
of the way they're each connected.
Um, and so, assortative mixing is do do
nodes mix with other nodes like
themselves, or, um, that are unlike
themselves? This can be further broken
down into like roles. We'll do role
discovery in a minute. And, um, so, you
can then see like how different types of
nodes in the network, uh, associate with
one another.
Yeah, so, then dispersion directly
measures how well connected the
neighbors of two nodes are, um,
connected. So, clustering coefficient
does this for one node. Uh, dispersion
does it for, um,
two nodes or paths with lengths greater
than one.
We calculate mean and median dispersion.
Often, in a a problem, you'll have a
bunch of networks, not
like one network. And so, um,
these are useful to get a profile for um
each of those networks uh for comparing
them. There are other techniques like uh
graph kernels, network motifs with like
sort of structural patterns in networks
are often used to create a profile for a
graph even in machine learning. And then
uh there are whole graph embeddings uh
that we'll look at.
Um interpreting dispersion is a little
bit difficult.
So, um now I'm going to cover random
graph models. We before when I said that
uh if you just do a random node sample
and then
uh use that uh that it screws up the
structure of your network. The reason
for that is that that corresponds to a
random graph model of a uh like an
Erdős-Rényi uh random graph,
uh which is not There are very few
real-world networks that fit that model.
So, um knowing what random graph model
fits your network tells you a lot about
its properties because uh those are well
characterized. And so, here we tried to
um
fit uh random graph model to uh a
network. It would be cool if there were
a simple easy way to um do this in like
one go, but I I'm not aware of one. So,
um
here we plot the degree histogram
of uh
What's the first one?
I see, we're comparing them. So, our
graph and the random graph generated the
Erdős-Rényi graph. So, you can see the
degree histogram of our graph versus uh
the degree histogram of the random
graph.
Again, the the axes here are not
aligned. It's just unfortunate, but you
can see that there are a lot more high
degree nodes in our actual data than
would be present in the Erdos-Renyi
network that was generated with similar
parameters.
So um
you know, that that tells you about the
impact of uh random node sampling. Um
The Barabasi-Albert model um generates a
random graph where nodes are added one
at a time and each node attaches to
existing nodes with a probability
proportional to the their degree. So,
this is also known as like the richer
get rich network type. If you're already
well connected, it's easy to form new
connections. This These fit real-world
graphs. Um
So, here if we compare uh we're sort of
checking multiple random graph
distributions to find one that fits. So,
here's our our network in terms of
degree and here's the Barabasi-Albert
uh network in terms of degree. Um
These are This is a scale-free type of
random graph model.
A lot of real-world networks like uh the
internet or um
uh you know, Wikipedia links uh
communication networks, you know,
they're real they're uh scale-free
networks where they have uh
a few nodes of very high degree and uh
many that are very low degree.
So, it's like a spoken hub model.
Um
Then we look at Price's model and do a
similar analysis. Uh looks like I had
trouble running that in time, so I I
didn't uh
use it. Um
You can generate a graph model that will
actually fit closely to the dis degree
distribution of your network. In fact,
in NetworkX, there are so many random
graph models. You can pick one that will
fit like the clustering coefficient and
the degree.
There are any number of parameters you
could choose to um
generate one. And this is useful for
like testing. If you wanted to generate
a network with similar properties to
your own uh
to see that um
it behaves in a way that's expected for
unit tests, for example. Um or like it's
in testing if you might not be able to
expose the real data, you could generate
random graph data and use it that way.
One deficiency that I found is that not
many
sampling algorithms take into account
the nodes' properties,
which you often really want to think
about as well. And so um kind of a
combined structural
uh property sampling algorithm like I've
I've never found one.
So, you can see this is the Erdos-Renyi
graph plotted with its properties.
Here are some others.
Here's a Watts-Strogatz
uh
random graph model.
So, it didn't quite find one that fits,
but um
it's still interesting to compare
because you can see how well they fit
with the theoretical properties of those
random graphs.
Uh so, now we're going to cover
centrality metrics. Centrality is a um
measure of a node's importance or um how
central it is to um
how it participates in a network.
So um
there are both local centralities and
graph level centralities. Um
Degree centrality or sorry, uh
there are local and uh
neighborhood and global centralities.
They um measure prominence either in
terms of the local connectivity of a
node, like degree uh centrality, how
many connections it has, uh or global
measure its prominence in terms of the
entire network. Eigenvector centrality,
um PageRank is an eigenvector centrality
uh many people are familiar with.
Closeness and betweenness are global
centralities. Uh I used to collect them.
Uh if you look at the
centrality algorithm documentation
for NetworkX, uh there are many.
And so, um they come from different
domains. Network science is a field
because the properties of networks
across, you know, biology and electrical
engineering and physics and uh uh you
know, uh studying the internet, they all
cross over
uh you know, with uh the the beauty of
graph math. Uh and so, um
you can get a centrality metric that's
based on the current flow in a in like
an actual circuit. Um and so, sometimes
it's like, "Well, okay, my network
doesn't have that." But actually, if you
look at you have to often have to go and
read the paper
uh or at least the abstract to see like
what specifically it's measuring and and
how they interpret it, and then try to
apply that interpretation to your
network. It's useful to find uh a
centrality that actually measures what
you're interested in, which is usually
like how central or important a node is
to your network. And so, you might have
to try different ones. You can We're
going to actually compare them uh here.
Uh so, we compute the eigenvector
centrality, and um
you can see we've added it to the
eigenvector field. We've got clustering
coefficient in there.
Uh relative degree is the degree
compared to the whole uh
you know, how like how many nodes there
are in the network. Uh sometimes I'll
compute you a log 10 of a metric just
because it spreads the distribution out.
So in graphistry you can plot it without
every node looking like really big or or
uh
the rest all looking small. Uh so we'll
do closeness centrality.
Uh it measures the average length of the
shortest path from a node to all other
nodes. So if you think about it, that
means running every path for every node
and it's very expensive. So um
you often just can't compute this. Uh
but I think it's between this
closeness is not as bad. Between this uh
like this is why I mentioned QGraph or
NetworkX.
Um
it's uh
you can run this on those, but it's
difficult in NetworkX itself for for
probably the size of a real network you
would be working with. Um if anyone
would like a class that uses QGraph,
it's hard to do in a public course uh
because setting up this is difficult
enough, let alone GPU support. Uh in a
private class I'll just set things up in
the cloud
uh and we can do them that way. Um
so here we're going to compute
betweenness centrality in NetworkX. It
has a very NetworkX-like
um
uh
you know, uh properties. Uh
Let me see if I can get this.
Uh my shell is so slow.
So you can see uh oh, did it finish?
Let's try that one more time.
So you can see it's using 1,400% so 14
cores. Uh and that's why it actually
finishes whereas if you uh
scroll up to the network x version
without a commented out, it will
probably take them till the end of time
or longer than you have. So, network it
is a cool way of applying uh multiple
cores or processors to a problem.
Um so, now we're going to visualize this
stuff in uh
Graphistry and uh let me pop it into its
own window.
Since I'm using Graphistry Hub, these
are actually um shareable.
So, this uh is if you think about doing
this in a company um you know, passing
these things around where you've you've
highlighted uh things that are
interesting for um
for your uh company uh or uh you can
screenshots are really effective like um
you know, look at this node, it's stands
out. Um for security analysis, this
stuff is really useful. Uh these this
network is very dense. Usually uh
networks involving like authentication
or that sort of thing are a lot easier
to um understand and work with. This is
uh
a really dense citation network.
Uh so, let's uh you can add histograms.
Let's add one for um
the degree will be the size of the node.
And uh we can adjust
the point size to make that
more meaningful. There's sort of uh
a lot of them are similar. So, um that
tells us something about the number of
citations that these papers are
receiving. Uh
and then we'll add another histogram for
um
eigenvector centrality and we'll set a
uh
Oops, that was the wrong one.
We'll set a uh color palette. So, um
Let's try this purple one.
Okay, let's try uh
So, you can see what it's actually doing
is um
it's indicating that um very few nodes
actually have uh
anything but the lowest eigenvector
centrality. Uh you can actually adjust
this. You can see that the This is why I
do log 10 actually, but um
you can change it so that it will uh
only do the lower ones.
If you can't see, so let's try one more
time.
Still don't get it. Now it's time to uh
kill it and use the eigenvector log 10.
So, now we get a better distribution.
So um
we'll try that one more time.
Now we get something that's more easy to
interpret. Now, you do need to remember
this is log scale, so the differences
you're looking at uh are on that scale.
So, that's important. Uh but you can see
that the eigenvector centralities um
vary more that you can see the size of
the node uh
versus
uh
the uh color of the node. So, you know,
there's a a very common amount of um
degree centrality in this network. Um
There is uh Actually, let me change
that.
Cuz it's a long tail.
Let me see if I can
>> That's a little bit better. You can see
that the um
the blue nodes, which I think are the
most dense, also have a fairly high
degree. So, um
we might interpret that as um
indicating that the how important a node
is locally is also fairly representative
of how important it is globally. You can
see in terms of degrees that there's a
lot of uh uniformity and um so that
that's like worth noting about the
network. That um if you get a bunch of
citations, you're most likely going to
get a lot more in the other papers that
you're connected to by association. And
so, uh that's a conclusion that you can
draw based on uh
based on this visualization.
And so, that's kind of the idea that you
can compare different metrics. This one
worked better. So, okay, closest first
to between this. I'm actually going to
run that. Um
Here's degree clustering versus degree
versus clustering coefficient. Um
It's just been an hour, so let me uh Oh,
this one is real. I popped that out
again.
And just to demonstrate this um that
it's shareable.
I'll share.
So, um you can invite people to your
org. Um that kind of thing. Uh
I don't know if they might have given me
like an account with that. I'm not sure
if that's um
But here uh
Let me try to copy the URL into Safari,
which I don't really use except to get
Wi-Fi on United cuz it never works and I
try another browser.
Uh So, you can see it'll open up. This
isn't logged in. Uh
That's interesting. Does it Does Safari
actually support SVG to this extent?
Evidently not.
Um so, use Chrome.
But um
let me get the uh
the layout to work a little bit better.
You can adjust expansion ratio.
No, that's not it.
Uh
No.
Huh, I'm not doing too good today.
Uh
Okay, I'll take it. That looks
reasonably explorable.
And so, um
what were the examples? Uh
Closeness first between this.
So,
um
All right, closeness has a pretty
reasonable uh
distribution for um
node size.
And you can
uh
adjust the point size.
You kind of want it in the middle where
there's a lot of small and and no
notable uh
larger ones. Um
and let me uh also do the um
Oh, I haven't computed between us yet.
Huh.
And then
let's do closeness versus uh clustering
coefficient.
So, we'll uh
No, not that. Oops.
Set coloring uh
Let me find a good gradient uh blue to
red. I think there's one.
Actually, that looks pretty good.
Categorical red. Uh that's not
maybe what I intended.
Uh here's a cool gradient.
Let me uh
So, here's another comparison. You can
see the white ones versus the uh
That's not that clear a relationship. Uh
let me compute some more metrics and
I'll show you that the differentials can
work, but um
there are some examples. Um
So, uh more on sampling networks. Um
often you like one type of one way to
sample a network is called like a 1.5
hop sample where you um take a node and
get its neighbors and then get all the
connections among them. Instead of two
hops, it's, you know, one and then the
the connections among them. This forms
an ego network. Uh there are books about
their properties and stuff, but um if
you need to zoom in, this is like a
really
uh powerful way to do so. Um
This is how uh
This is a 1.5 hop network of um
uh my my brother's LinkedIn network. He
was in some secret club. That's what
this is blocked out in the video game
industry. He didn't want to um
display, but you can see um even though
we're losing the context of the this
next hop out, uh
where you can you still get a lot of
interesting structure.
And so that's an example also of a
snowball sample. So um it's where you
start with uh
one node and then start hopping out. So
you can get like a first-degree snowball
sample,
uh second-degree, 1.5 degree. You can
always add 0.5 at the end to say that
it's going to connect among all the
nodes. Uh
and it
So we get uh a thousand nodes. So uh
this little ball of fur has a cool
snowball sampler. Uh try to use little
ball of fur rather than using your own
stuff. It's uh I keep it actively
working with the latest versions of um
Python libraries, though I did not uh
write it up. Just fixed a few bugs and
things so I could use it in class. It
actually starts with uh a node and will
start hopping out multiple degrees uh
until it reaches a certain number of
nodes. Um
And so in in terms of node sampling,
there are really two major
bodies. Uh like one is um
base sort of snowball-like algorithms
and the other are random walks, where
you'll just randomly uh walk out from a
graph for uh
a certain number of hops. Um
So you can see here's a uh
snowball sample. Um
This is about a node of interest. So I
mean, if we we've been looking at this
whole network and it's just a hairball
that's really difficult to interpret,
but now we're in more of an
investigative context where um
we have zoomed in on a node of interest.
Uh I forget what it was It was a There's
a landmark paper in physics.
Um
So, I think it's uh
M-theory as a matrix model has a degree
of 1,219.
Um
And so, this is its uh network. Um By
the way, the um
colors can also be clusters. Um
so, if you uh compute like modularity,
uh I'm not I do that in the next
notebook, actually. But, these are more
explorable. Um
You could check this out and then go
check out this other paper and um
you know, the properties are there. If
for your own data, these would be
probably more meaningful and uh so,
investigations get a lot more
interesting. Then, you could do a a
sample on uh you know, that that node
and and investigate out uh in that way.
Um
Uh so, supernodes, whenever you're
building a knowledge graph, there's a
step where you reach and uh your
algorithm dies. It happens almost always
uh in real-world networks. There'll be a
node that contains so many connections,
it often can contain no real
information. When I built uh for this
company Relato, I started to build like
marketing applications of graph
analytics on business graphs like
like I mentioned before. Um Microsoft
had a program where you could partner at
a partnership graph. You could partner
with Microsoft to get a free version of
Office. Anyone Any business could. And
so, literally, almost every company that
I found in this
I wrote a market report on the big data
market by doing a snowball sample two
and a half hops out from uh
Cloudera, Hortonworks, MapR, and uh the
other one that was around that. I forget
the name. And um
Yeah, Microsoft was a supernode. So, in
that case, I just deleted it. Um that's
often the solution because uh for graph
algorithms they're pretty much a deal
stopper. You can also seek to find the
connections from them that actually
matter. One strategy that is scalable in
terms of computation is to look at the
degree of the nodes it's connected to
and often drop the low degree nodes.
That's commonly
acceptable if you think about it like
those might be companies in that context
that don't really partner. So, if you're
interested in partnership graphs, that's
noteworthy. You could look at that, but
not in a graph context. You can make a
list of those and you know, do some
analysis on their properties. So, you
can pretty much get rid of them.
I'll show you how how to do role
discovery to do that, but um,
Little Ball of Fur, as you can see it
has a bunch of different uh, sampling
methods. The edge sampling methods I
haven't used this much, but um, they are
an entirely different approach. Um,
exploration sampling uh,
you select a node uniformly at random
and then explore the nodes in its
vicinity. That's what a snowball sample
is. Um, this paper is Sampling from
Large Graphs by
uh, Faloutsos and Leskovec from 2006.
It's really funny. Um, Jure Leskovec's
like my graph hero. He's many people's
graph hero. He teaches CS224W.
Like every other day I'll come across a
paper and he he's like the guy on the
the the top. Um, it's just really funny
how often I end up reading his work
going back to like the early 2000s and
he's still uh, you know, teaches that
class and does research uh, on the
cutting edge of graph machine learning
now.
Uh, but it started out his class was
about network science. So, if you want
to learn more network science, go and
look at the CS224W
videos from like a decade ago and it was
called actually uh, something to do with
network science and it became graph ML
over time. So, here's that PageRank
sampler I mentioned. Um, we get its
properties um
we visualize.
So, um the idea is that if you if you
think about it like um I said that this
would maintain the node graph's
properties. So, just to look at it, this
actually resembles structurally the um
cuz this is the default rendering
properties, it does resemble the entire
graph that we looked at earlier. And so,
um you can kind of tell that the uh rule
of thumb from Palutsos and Leskovec does
actually work. Um and that's really
important if you were getting like uh
doing a graph embedding or something
like that. If you really trans- if you
sample poorly and then embed, your
embeddings are not going to be as
effective in machine learning as if you
did a sample that actually maintains the
structure of the network.
So, I've seen instances where a sample
was done badly, like a few percent
random node sample, and then people work
really really hard on the machine
learning, and it's like we threw most of
the signal away at step one, and and
that's why it's a difficult problem.
Uh so, that's why I cover sampling. Um
All right. So, uh now we've got uh 45
minutes for graph machine learning.
Uh
I hope the approach here is valuable. Um
before
um
embeddings really uh graph machine
learning was an exercise in uh
like uh lots and lot actually I've got
uh slides. Um
you had to compute many uh features,
and
um
it was really like labor-intensive.
Uh I wanted to make a recommender system
for companies that you should sell to,
and there were like 80 80 metrics in a
reference paper that you had to uh
implement like one at a time. Um
Here's uh
here it is.
So, here's um feature engineering for
link prediction in 2010. Um this is that
reference paper that has so many
different metrics that you had to apply.
Um
and here's like a a graph embedding at a
you know, a graph being converted into a
2D representation. And so, uh
as I mentioned Leskovec, he was one of
the guys on the paper for node 2 vec
second graph embedding. Um and it really
changed my life because I'd spent like a
year doing feature engineering for this
uh Relato business graph. And then a uh
a graph embedding reproduced it uh you
know, those metrics more effectively in
like a single go. Uh so, it was a really
disruptive uh algorithm. But here's me
with Gremlin and TinkerPop against
JanusGraph. Gremlin was uh it's still
used some. It's a a rather obscure but
very powerful uh
query language um
for uh graph databases. TinkerPop was
this project that worked with all like
all the graph databases around at the
time. Neo4j was on it. And um Cypher and
uh GQL are I think it's the new one's
called uh are much better languages for
uh humans to learn. Um
but uh so, here you can see we're
computing uh like the degree of yeah,
the the degree of nodes and that's one.
Uh and then I compute eigenvector
centrality and that's another. Um but
then network embeddings are uh they
initially came from word 2 vec uh where
you take a heterogeneous network and uh
you can do random walks uh on a graph
and they form a sequence. And then you
can apply text embedding methods. So, um
then you can convert uh a graph to its
uh
it's
uh lower dimensionality representation.
I think I have to zoom out slightly
here.
So, first we do graph machine learning
by hand is what I'm I'm trying to
summarize um so that you learn what
graph embeddings and then graph neural
networks do for you.
Uh it's really uh I think important to
understand that otherwise representation
learning feels like magic and uh it's
more difficult to perform and and and
tune. Um
So, here we load our citation graph.
Um
and uh
So, here we'll do some feature
engineering for node classification.
Here is that uh Oh, here are those
slides actually.
Um then we're going to store uh the
features by column in a features uh
NumPy array um
and we'll have one with uh that's X,
that's the features, and one that's Y,
that's uh I see we just extended it in
this case with the uh Y feature. So,
we'll just append them.
Um
Just be careful uh if you um
rerun cells, sometimes you can double up
your um features. So, you can see um
uh
Here I get duplicate feature columns. Um
So, here we'll compute some NetworkX
centrality methods. Here's degree,
in-degree. In-degree and out-degree are
just the the number of inbound and
outbound connections. Eigenvector
centrality um
we're assigning them to the NetworkX
graph via set node attributes. Here um
the uh
eigenvector centrality for a
disconnected graph is not well defined,
so we have to take the largest
component, make it undirected, run the
metric, assign back on the full network
zeros to everything, and then if it's
present, assign the largest component's
eigenvector. Uh you could do this on the
smaller components as well to get a
metric for everything.
Um
so then we add that to our NumPy array
of features. Um
Uh community detection, this is
something you can use especially in uh
graphistry. Uh it'll show you the
clusters of a network. This might show
journals, for example, um in uh or
conferences. Um
Modularity uh is a really uh fairly
simple algorithm. A form of modularity
um is used in graph rag. Uh forget the
name of the It's an improved one in
terms of efficiency and capability, but
um
you know, when they cluster uh
around concepts,
uh
to um
enhance rag, this is what they're doing.
Um
Oh, and this was an example. Uh so I
took this uh
cluster size histogram,
and I fed it into this prompt.
Uh
I have a citation graph of physics
papers, and just explained what the data
looked like, and the output totally
checked out, actually.
Um Like I thought about it, and I looked
at it, and I looked the stuff up, and it
was like community structure, there are
a few large communities of paper. The
largest had Like it really did a really
good job, and this was actually GPT-4,
and not 4o. Uh so you can, you know,
feed your histograms into an LLM, and uh
provided you can understand the output
well enough to check it, uh really get
some pretty good uh descriptions for
like reports and things.
Um So then I assigned the cluster ID via
label encoder as a feature. Uh
These are the different clusters.
So, this is something I really wanted to
show you. Um there's a
community detection via clustering
algorithms, but then there's also role
discovery via Rolex and Refex. These
algorithms are really cool
that I've used in the past.
And so,
you can see on the left there's a role
in red of a type of node and this is
based on the connectivity patterns.
Um
And then on the right there are the the
clusters in modularity that are that are
communities. And so, you can see that
each community has nodes in it that are
the same as in other communities and
that's really noteworthy and important
to understand. Um you know,
one thing I've I've done with role
discovery. I'm going to show you
network motifs
in a minute and
they can be used you know, each a
position in a network motif is can
correspond to a different
a
structural role. So, in the AML world
you you might have ultimate beneficial
ownership where you have um
So, here's a really simple
um
network motif for um
multiple path indirect ownership. This
came from a um
poster from
Bureau van Dijk. And um
so, this company A is actually the
ultimate beneficial owner. So, that
could be a structural role.
Um
community B are the companies designed
to obscure. It owns a majority ownership
in a layer of companies that in
aggregate own company C. This is a form
of hiding ultimate beneficial ownership
from A to C.
There's now a lot of reporting stuff
where you have to report the ultimate
beneficial owner
and that this is why because you can
really get around
you know people use this to not pay
taxes. They use it for to obscure
financial crime. This was a more
interesting one we found where a woman
named Olga had acquired a corporation
services company that made a bunch of
companies and they were then used in
some financial transactions and the clue
that this was all being done around one
laundromat or like money laundering
network was that the officer names
overlapped a lot and they weren't exact
matches. So what I ended up having to do
was to compare the names using sentence
transformers
to get like a vector distance and a
threshold and then you could use a set
metric to calculate like how similar
each company was
and that's uh
something that you often have to do once
you
like it's frequently the case with graph
neural networks that
you you can get an embedding of the text
features or the you can do a structured
embedding of just like database fields
and those provide the starting features
of a node and then
you can do this with graph embeddings as
well. Those will then be distributed
among the network to learn their context
in terms of structure in the graph and
this is why graph machine learning works
so well. That structure is a lot richer
because the relational bias of the model
fits the actual phenomena in the world.
So if you think about
you could encode a list of people in a
single table and it would describe them
thoroughly. Maybe this is the census and
then you could encode it as individuals
and their relationships with people and
then still have those properties. It's
going to be a much richer
representation.
So, I used Rolex for to create this
poster I did at Relato for um
O'Reilly's conference Strata. So, this
is the role detection on the graph. The
blue ones were, as I mentioned, like
companies that didn't have a lot of
partnerships. The
green ones are large companies that are
magnets for partnerships. The red ones
are medium-sized companies that form a
lot of partnerships among themselves
as well as with the um
the green nodes. And when I did this
analysis, I don't have it in the
notebook, you can actually compute like
with a bar plot, you know, the various
properties of
the nodes in each structural role and
you can get a good profile. They do this
in the paper
of those nodes so you can really
understand what each role does. Those
are often interpretable if it's your
data so you can really understand
like when this was a method that we
intended to pursue for finding actual
money launderers or terrorists to use
role discovery to sort of fingerprint
different nodes. Like one that I knew we
could fingerprint was like attorneys,
you know, because like attorneys could
be associated with money launderers for
instance, but that doesn't make them a
money launderer
necessarily.
You know, they're attorneys often
represent criminals legitimately and so
defining that role would have been one
that we were looking to um
discover. As far as this network goes,
I ran Rolex Refex. This is a pipi
package and I got seven roles.
Um
I'm assigning those to uh
the graph as property. This scales
somewhat. Like it doesn't scale to very
large networks.
Yeah.
Is it called Rolex? Uh I think it's
called Refex.
A graph role.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's really neat. It's very uh
practical practically uh
usable. They use a form of embedding
uh like an early form of embedding to
accomplish it. Um
it'll be interesting to see what's
followed this. I haven't looked, but
there's probably better stuff now.
Yeah.
So, we have created this get roles
method and we associate the role um
then we label and code them to get this
in our machine learning. So, now we have
the structural role as a feature. That's
going to really probably help. Uh I
don't know if I analyze feature
importances, but my intuition is that
the structural role will help. The uh
machine learning we're going to
do is to to classify uh
papers into their journal since we have
that data and we can test against it.
It's kind of a uh
you might not really do that, but it was
a reasonable task to uh do feature
engineering on. And so, uh we set the
community via modularity, but we also
set the Rolex role. And when you have
both of those, you get a lot richer in
data that's interpretable by you, but
also by uh a classifier or um you know,
a machine learning algorithm. So, we're
using the pagerank sampler to uh get a
sample.
Um
font size looks okay.
You kind of have to learn to play with
those until you get you can learn to get
something that's easier to explore, but
um
So, what I'll do now is uh this is kind
of the the finale in terms of cool uh
visualizations. Hopefully, uh I'm going
to do the same thing I did in that
poster that where the color was the the
community and
um
Uh what did I do?
Edge influence and expansion ratio.
Hm.
It's weird that it worked a second ago.
You can reload if you don't like the
state that your um notebook gets into.
I'm just going to go with this and uh
So, we can add a histogram for
um
community. It's an integer, so you can
see the different counts. Um community
as color works really well.
Um
Wait, did I do point? Yeah, that's that
doesn't work. You don't want to do uh
community in size. Then, there's
categorical um
palettes you can use. So, you can see
here we're getting uh
Let's turn the point size down some.
And um let's turn the point opacity
down.
It turns out it's quite high.
So, you can start to see that the small
nodes um
And uh so, you can see our communities
do tend to cluster like uh we click on a
green node, we see a lot of green nodes
it's connected to. This uh is kind of,
you know, shows us verifies the logic of
the um
the communities and then uh
Looking at um
the Rolex role. Uh so, I'm Actually,
this sort of doesn't make sense,
actually, but let me try uh
point size. Yeah, this actually works
better as a uh
opposing thing.
So, here are the Rolex roles.
Uh
um
if you think about the way the others
looked, this is the way their
communities worked uh
just a second ago. You can go back and
forth.
These are the communities, uh but you
don't know like what type of node makes
up each community. Uh but you do if you
look at the role. And so, you can
analyze these side by side and see that
there's this green role that uh you can
actually click around and then look at
their properties and and you could do
this via statistical analysis suggested.
Um
I can send you code if someone needs to
do this. Uh it's in an old project, but
um
you can uh look at like the degree
distribution. You might look at um
a few green nodes uh or you might look
at some red ones.
Let's look at a prominent red one.
Uh so, red seem to be uh a lower degree
than green. Is that accurate?
Sometimes it's evident and sometimes
it's not. Uh blue seem to have a low
degree, though. That's a property we can
infer about that node type. And so, um
there's also filtering. So, let me click
on a blue node. Let's say that we
determine, as I mentioned before, like
in the partnership graph, or these are
unimportant papers because they haven't
been cited. Uh let me zoom in so I can
get a um
Oh, those are I'm not actually clicking
it. There we go. So, um
So, get a uh
roll Rolex rolls. So, uh roll zero. So,
often the one that's not important comes
out as uh roll zero. So, we're going to
do um
unequal
to roll zero.
All right. So, now we remove those from
our analysis and you can do this along
with community. So, um if we just want
to look at uh the journal that is
clustered into um
we could use that and you can add them.
So um
you can uh
So, I think you can actually filter this
object.
I wish I remembered how to do this. You
can get like a snowball sample in this
uh program. Um
uh
Neo Mayorovich on LinkedIn will show you
um but I can't actually recall at the
moment how to do that. Uh but it's neat
and so you can drill down uh and things
like that. You know, so now we might be
able to um e- more easily analyze the
roles. Uh
And so, probably part of this is uh
you know, assortativity. That's
basically what a roll roll detection
community detection or uh roll discovery
is doing. It's looking for uh nodes that
uh have good assortive mixing together.
And so, it's a clustering on that axis
instead of what is well connected with
one another.
Uh so, what's similar versus what's well
connected.
All right. So, we're going to classify
nodes into journals. Um I create a
uh scikit-learn pipeline. Um
I tried to get XGBoost working last
night, but I didn't have time. So, it's
an exercise for the reader.
Um
So, there are the model predictions. I
created a score function. So, we're not
doing great at that task.
Should have picked one that was easier,
but um
Here's the XGBoost thing I couldn't get
working. Uh So, here we're going to
actually
um
We're going to add the abstract
paraphrase embedding to
our our task as a feature. Um
That um
increased accuracy from 0.29 to 0.31.
This is what feature engineering was
like. Um You often worked it for a long
time to get a very small improvement. Um
You still feature engineer with deep
learning. It's just different. Um
You know, it's automating a lot of it
for you, and so it's more about the
introduction of new signals rather than
the refinement of the signals you've
got. I use a standard distribution
scalar um to
extract, you know, to remove unnecessary
features
require that.
So, here we come to network embeddings
methods, and this is going to be a lot
simpler. So, we have this PageRank-based
sampler to get something small.
Um
5,000 nodes, 35,000 edges. Um
Then we DeepWalk was the first graph
embedding.
You often find, by the way, in graph
databases algorithms for um
embeddings that are quite old. So, you
know, like a decade or
like Neo4j has a quite old network
embedding library. There's this main
one, but they have actually improved it
and extended it
uh be class and property aware. So,
their stuff is actually not bad, but um
often you find that they're uh older,
and so if you use a library like Karate
Club or another library like NetworkX
has um
some graph embeddings, I believe, for
more scalable stuff, you uh can get
something more state-of-the-art.
Um
so right off the bat, the score is
actually not as good, but that is an old
algorithm.
Um so then Node2Vec came next. You see
how this is a big thing, why I mentioned
that some graph TVs have old algorithms.
We got like a 5% score increase across
the board pretty much by using
uh Node2Vec instead of DeepWalk.
Laplacian Eigen, Karate Club has a bunch
of graph embeddings. Um
someone asked lot yesterday whether it
supported multiplex networks. It
doesn't, but you can uh give it initial
features that there are um attribute
embeddings that it has that will use
those.
Um
So um
another task that you perform on graphs
in machine learning is uh link
prediction. Uh this is a really powerful
task. Um node classification is uh
you know, you can you can kind of
they can cross over. If you had a link a
node that defined a class connecting to
it would be a classification. So, they
sort of meet in the middle.
Um
link prediction is really powerful like
um
to uh if you have edges and you need
know there are more and you want to
extend your data to to contain more of
those unknown edges. Um
it can be very powerful for um
like entity resolution can use um link
prediction.
Uh you uh assign like same as edges
essentially, And then you use connected
components to um
to group those, and then you can uh get
your uh different uh resolved entities
out. Here, I'm just computing a bunch of
uh
uh pair, you know, features on uh pairs
of nodes. So, uh I I Damac Adar, these
are all from NetworkX um pair features.
There is one in here that was like
harmonic
that did the task so well that I didn't
use it. Uh it sort of a defeated the
purpose of of teaching machine learning
for this task. It it uh it got like a
90% uh
accuracy uh on its own. It very well fit
it very well. Um
But, for um so, that was the manual link
prediction. And then to show you kind of
what it's what embeddings do for you, uh
here we deepwalk embed both nodes, and
then uh concatenate them.
And um then we do a classification. So,
uh link prediction is is sort of a form
of classification where you encode pairs
of nodes, and then um
perform uh like a binary classification.
Um
So, you can see here we get our score.
Um You can then add these uh if there's
a link, you can add it back to your
knowledge graph and enrich it. And so,
um if you can get creative with this and
do some It's got a broad
I think prediction has a broader way of
applications. Um So, I must confess a
lot of the GNN content um
I I talk about uh sparse representations
versus dense in embeddings. Um
It was the case that, you know, data was
encoded where it would be like a one for
this feature, and all the rest would be
zeros. And deep learning took off when
there were dense representations where
you have a vector where all the values
count, and it
uh maps the meaning of a uh
a word to uh this embedded space where
you can do like math. King minus man
plus woman equals queen.
Um
Graph convolutional networks uh you have
initial features and um
there's message passing between nodes uh
and then the summary that's done is a
convolution just like in a CNN in a um
a uh
imaging uh you know image classification
or something. Um
dropouts are common. Then you do another
convolution um and you ultimately get a
node embedding. Uh you can also get an
embedding off a whole for a whole graph
this way.
Um so here we show how to build a graph
convolutional network in uh
uh
DGL. DGL, there are two libraries you'd
want to use for graph neural networks.
The first that I find a little more
convenient is PyG. Uh the hardest part
of I've of DGL and PyG is actually
creating a data loader for your network
using their interfaces. It can even be
easier to just do your own.
Uh
Oh no, I need to plug. Uh let me turn
this down.
Um
it can be easier to uh create your own
um
but uh DGL takes a NetworkX library
perspective and um
in uh PyG you use more like PyTorch
objects and uh you know PyTorch
features. Uh I've tried both. I I I
started doing DGL for the class and um
I uh ended up moving uh
This is a helpful video. Uh
So here's a simple um DGL implementation
of a graph convolutional network. Um
the uh
way graph neural networks work um
uh so you have uh this is image
convolution whereas uh in uh graph
convolution, you message pass all
connected nodes to a node and then apply
convolution to uh those messages. Um
and so it works very similar. Here's the
message passing. Uh
the number of layers in your uh
network, so for instance uh
Uh
Wait, where did I go?
There we are. Um the number of layers in
uh
this code, you can see there are two
graph convolutional layers. Uh so we
apply one and then relu and then another
um and that's the forward operation for
the message passing um
then we pass in the uh features and the
uh
dimensions of the uh classes. Um
So that corresponds to the um number of
uh
message passing layers to the degree. So
a two layer convolutional GCN will have
uh the second degree messages will reach
each node. Um there's the the number you
will have varies. Um you can have very
few in chemistry. Uh you can have a
bunch in some other domains. Um but uh
the way this works, you can see that um
A gets its uh messages from the blue
node, the red node, and the green node.
Uh but the red node has two neighbors,
which is A and C. So that's where its
message, you know, and there's summarize
layer that's convolution here at each
step. Um
This is actually an important like Neo4j
their embedding uh like you know,
algorithm.
Uh their G GNN will actually just take
the mean. So um you use your own your
PyG, you can get more sophisticated
algorithms
in terms of that layer. Um
All right, I've got 15 minutes and
uh
So, we do we train a G a GCN uh
then we train a graph attention network.
Note that this is quite similar. To do a
basic GNN is actually as simple as you
know this blob. Uh it gets a lot more
complex in tuning them
and that sort of thing which is kind of
akin to feature engineering in the
manual layer.
Uh yeah.
And uh yeah.
Yeah thanks.
You can also do link prediction with
GNNs. Here we're loading a Cora is I
think a citation network. Um
We'll show an example of doing that. Um
GraphSAGE, I think this was the first
algorithm that had
a more sophisticated summarization than
uh
convolution. You can it puts like an
LSTM, I think, there. This is where you
put transformers because you're just
getting a sequence like you would in a
text context.
It also it employs a sampling algorithm
that allowed GNNs to scale to much
larger data sets. Um
the last thing I want to show there's
this I started a notebook. I have a lot
of trouble getting PySpark code to run
in notebooks just period that aren't
Databricks notebooks. I just can't I
couldn't get graph frames I mean PySpark
to run in
even the simple stuff in a Docker
container. I think it might be because I
built the container in Linux and then
loaded it on OS 10 in a different
architecture and it might have thrown
off the JVM. But I do have this really
cool thing.
I'm a big fan of NordVPN not for the
VPNs they're all kind of the same but it
has this meshnet. So you start a client
like I've got one on my phone. Let me
see if I can get it to uh
pop up.
If I activate it and you can VPN between
everything and it takes like uh
like 2 seconds to set up. So I go to
manage devices.
I can see from my phone uh this machine
Heracles. Uh
it takes some it takes a while for
mobile devices to come up. But I've
essentially got a SSH window open to my
home computer.
Um
Heracles, it's going to be a little slow
but um
Let me I should definitely
What the
Where went my window?
This is new to me.
That's a video game.
Um
I think I have to stop sharing. Do you
ever seen you banish a window in the
Never had this happen.
Let me quit it.
Let me force quit it.
I can't even bring that up.
My window disappeared.
Which
Uh all of them.
Let me just close that down.
Yeah, I it quit I hit clicked hide on
the thing that shows windows in it.
Now I can't
Let me try.
I can't access any of my windows now.
Should we take this? Yeah, thanks.
Screen sharing.
Okay, now I can.
All right, so uh
So I'm going to run if you look in this
folder um You still have the the stream.
I don't know where uh
Is it
What do you mean?
On the stream?
Sorry. So, on the web chat I'll bring it
up.
I had to close my browser and then Okay.
I'm trying to get you to restart back
in.
Um
What's the address?
Didn't he he emailed it to you, right?
Yeah, I guess I can log into my email.
Maybe bookmark this one
just in case.
Is that good?
I'm going to add
and share each of the screens.
Choose my screen now.
Okay, cool. If you could just mute
yourself.
I think I'm on.
I'm still struggling. I don't know.
It's difficult to see.
Yeah. Yeah, if you just mute. Yeah.
Okay. That's really fine. All right.
Um
All right, I won't hide this thing. I'll
move it. That's really screwed
everything up. Um
So, um if you look in uh
graph ML class stats
there is some stuff. Um
there's this download script, so you can
use it to download. I do uh motif search
over um
uh
it's uh Stack Exchange data. So, this
would work on even the biggest Stack
Overflow, but I got stats.meta so that
it would run very quickly on like a a
personal computer. Um GraphFrames is a a
library that can do graph processing on
very large networks um like many
billions of nodes and edges um or even
more um
so um if you you can actually run the
download script and it'll
it's a little CLI
and it'll show you how to download the
data so you can do like download uh
like stats
if we just wanted to get the stats and
it'll download it from stat the archive
and unzip it. It's a 7z format, but um
what I'm going to do is run uh
PySpark with GraphFrames and I'm going
to give it some memory
um
GraphFrames you can find by searching um
this is its docs page.
um
So, um first I have the script XML to
parquet. I just convert the XML of the
um
Stack Exchange data to um parquet so
it's easy to work with. Um and then in
this graph uh is an example this graph
file
is an example of knowledge graph
construction for large networks um and
what you can basically see is that uh I
do all sorts of um
careful checks of the data structure
um when you're in um
like uh Spark you're working with data
that doesn't have some of the tabular
constraints that a well-formed data set
might have. So, um
you have to be very careful. Uh one
thing you have to do for graph frames is
that you can only have one type of node,
something I'm going to change
uh at least in the interface level. So,
you have to actually add every field to
every node and you just leave the ones
blank that don't actually fit. Um
you can still of course express the
logic of different node types because
you get to use the data frame interface
to filter and perform operations. Uh but
yeah, there's they become a bunch of uh
paths.
Um but what I wanted to show you is um
this stuff. So,
let me load some
Let me load the data.
So, I loaded. Um these are the data
types. There's um posts, tags, uh which
contain metadata about a tag, badges
which users earn, users, votes, like a
vote for something, uh upvote, downvote,
uh spam vote, uh post links where one
post links to another post.
And um
you give graph frames a uh node data
frame and a relationship data frame.
You can show the edges.
Um
you can show the nodes that uh
Oh, it's actually vertices. I'm going to
add an alias. I I started taking over
maintenance of this because I think it's
so cool.
Um so, you can see there's like a bunch
of uh fields from all the the types. Um
You Some algorithms require you to set a
checkpoint directory in the Spark
context, um which is the RDD interface.
So, you can get like connected
components. This is really why most
people use the library as a part of
their entity resolution pipeline. Once
you've used like link prediction to
connect nodes, you then use connected
components to group them uh
into node clusters.
Let me see what it's doing.
So, you can see it's using uh
a bunch of cores to do its work. Um
Here are the uh component IDs. Uh
This is just going to be the uh lowest I
think we just changed it's the most
common node in the in the uh
the cluster. So, zero is or the most
connected node in the cluster.
Um
You can see cluster zero has 45,000
uh
size and the rest are quite small.
Um so, here uh
You can see in the read me I actually
show um
like examples of um
network motifs. So, these are
directional motifs. There's only so many
of these patterns if you ignore like
node type and the properties. And so, I
essentially start searching for these.
This is one of the first free-form motif
searches I've actually done. Usually
when working in like a money laundering
context, we would have domain knowledge
and search for a pattern and then I
would search for variations. This is
cool way to do it because then you you
constrain the computation space so that
you can search for motifs sometimes that
are so expensive
you can't complete them but we're going
to look at a triangle which is G4.
So it's this uh
number 10 number nine right here it's a
triangle where all the nodes go in the
same loop.
Um
so it's a continuous triangle.
And um
what path does so you can look at paths.
Uh the the most G.dot.find is the motif
stuff. It returns a path that fits that
so you can see A the edge E is the edge
B the second node the second edge C is
the the last node and E is the edge off
it going back to A. Um so you can then
process this using data frame
uh methods and to do like anything you
want. Um so like I have this three edge
count method that just zones in zones in
on the the type of the node and the
relationship type. And so it then
displays those
and this is just saying what kind of
pattern is in type so you can see here
like the only uh
nodes that form that pattern type are
you know link loops. Okay so that's
very simple but we can get more complex.
Um
so divergent triangles this is uh
this is number 10. We have
branching off and then one of them is
connected by a directional edge. Graph
frames only does direct directed
graphs is something else I'd like to
add to it but you can represent them by
undirected edges by two connections. So,
uh that type has um tags that uh connect
to posts that connect to uh
you know, uh tags and then links. So, um
this you have to be careful. So, it goes
A to B, A to C. So, uh A has a relation
type of tag to posts. And then um
A has a relationship type of uh tag to
another post.
And um
then finally, the posts are linked for
this top row.
Or you just have uh post links again.
Um so, this is sort of equivalent like
if you've ever done uh an analysis Yeah.
It's It's just uh No, it's not a Cypher
representation. It just happens to be
the same thing.
Uh yeah, um th- there was a offer to add
Cypher to Spark at one point, and I
don't think it went well.
Um unfortunately.
But um
So then, uh we will look at um
G6, which is a continuous path.
So uh
if you look at uh this is uh this one
where you have all in the same
direction. So, you see there's a bunch
of these. This basically becomes
equivalent to like when you would you
might look at uh I think it's an
affiliation query where you might look
at what what like node value uh
table values associate with other table
values. This is a way to explore a graph
the way you might in SQL explore a table
with group buys. Um and then I'm doing a
group buy on this data in this
three-edge count method to get counts
for each uh section. So, that's what's
kind of cool about um um
So, I'm doing a group by on that the
type of node and each relationship type
to get a count for each thing.
Um but the paths
are actually the raw nodes properties
and the raw edges properties. Now, you
can uh
of course select portions of them.
That's why you can't see them, but um
you can do like paths. uh
select
a.type
type
e.relationship
You can do anything. Um
So, these are all votes being cast and
um I think there's uh we can show
another property like a.vote type
I think that's a field.
So, we can see those are all upvotes,
but let's see if that's representative.
What are all the combinations?
Oh, I'm over time.
Um but hopefully you can get the the
idea and this So, this directly applies
to like ultimate beneficial ownership
patterns. You can map those. Um it
applies to uh money laundering patterns.
We know we worked on uh AML KYC stuff.
We found that like the label quality was
so poor the for um detecting like bad
guys that um we came into it thinking
that our mission would be to build a
graph neural network and build the best,
you know, neural representation of the
economy that we possibly could. That
would be the main asset of the company
and we'd basically refine it and take
over the world with it in various ways.
Um the label quality was so poor in
terms of where it was where they were
present and how connected the um
how connected the actual bad guys were.
They were fairly disconnected, that uh
machine learning just really didn't
work.
And so pattern detection turned out to
be a much better approach. Um
And this is how we did it. Um
Uh on the like the
No, that's actually really interesting.
That's a great idea. That would be
awesome. Yes, so you can basically throw
any metric that we worked with. So I
haven't actually done that at all.
Um any network science metric, this is
what I meant about them being really
powerful with you when used with machine
learning.
You could throw that into a motif
search. So you know, someone in this
role, if we detected an attorney as I
mentioned,
you could then look for attorneys
representing uh bad guys, attorneys
representing anyone,
or
attorneys representing a bunch of bad
guys. Since you can group by on the
path, you could group by the um
like the sanction status of a node.
Uh you know, and the attorney's name.
And so you could then get quickly get a
pattern of like a motif. These are the
sort of property graph motifs. They're
not well defined in the literature
except in the graph frames paper, but
you can group by in in these essentially
and get counts. And so
you know, like how many like let's look
at attorneys that have at least five
criminal clients. Those are either money
launderers or criminal defense
attorneys.
And in an in affiliate in the network
we're looking at more like someone that
facilitates money laundering, like
Mossack Fonseca or something. Um
But uh
Uh what do I want to look at? Um
I I I forgot.
Uh
So, we'll group by the um
the type again.
But, also the vote type.
Oops.
Uh what did I do?
I see. You have to do this, which is
kind of annoying.
Um
This is what I do in that method.
dot uh
This is something I need to fix. Um
I'll just dot add.
All right. I'll do what I know works uh
for the um
Think fits. that works.
Okay. So, you can see uh you know, just
this is we could extend this into
relationships where it would get more
interesting. I got to wrap up, but um
you can see so we've got vote and the
type up vote is very common um down
vote.
Um we could extend this and look at the
relationship type and uh we could see
like what you know, how one pattern we
could easily implement here is how many
like an interesting pattern would be
like what posts get a bunch of up votes
and are then flagged as spam or
something. So, this would be like a
potential network motif for detecting
like uh you know, rating fraud
potentially. And so, um
yeah, we're looking at your paths and
doing group buys uh
it's it's it's like as I mentioned like
a new kind of uh network motif that they
created.
All right, that wraps up my talk. Thank
you everyone.